the Joe Rogan experience don't think b12
you know that's the thing that came up
in the film a number of times so we
should talk about that a little bit
because there was some actually just you
know factually inaccurate information
about b12 and I want to correct
so the claim this is slide 55 Jamie
James said b12 is not made by animals
it's made by bacteria that these animals
consume in the soil and water before
industrial farming farm animals and
humans can get b12 by eating traces of
dirt on plant foods or by drinking water
from rivers or streams but now because
it pesticides and antibiotics and
chlorine that killed bacteria this
vitamin even yeah that produces a
vitamin even farm animals have to be
given b12 supplements that's just all
false that's all just factually wrong so
first of all b12 is made by bacteria but
it's animals don't get it from consuming
soil and water the the b12 is made by
bacteria in their gut so in ruminants
like cows the in the rumen which is a
chamber in the stomach the bacteria
convert cobalt that they get from grass
that they eat into cobalamin which is
b12 and then they are for gut fermenters
so they can absorb the b12 they the
bacteria produce in their intestines and
utilize that themselves so primates
including humans also have bacteria that
make b12 but we're hindgut fermenters so
we cannot absorb the b12 that our own
gut bacteria make well that's not
exactly true chimps and gorillas can but
that's only because they eat their own
poo so that is one potential strategy
for meeting your you 12 just put that
out there you can because aphasic we
will find ethical food eaters the whole
community now of read ethical eaters is
now a new subreddit so so so we cannot
get b12 from our own gut bacteria right
and that and if there is an e b12 in
soil it's only from manure you know
that's coming from
there's also zero evidence that b12 is
fed to cattle and there's no evidence
that humans have ever been able to meet
their b12 needs from just eating soil
and water if you pull up slide 56 Jamie
Jack Norris who's a vegan diet ition you
know we don't agree on a lot of things
but I appreciate his rigor with the
science he has a big article on b12 on
this website and it said he says the
suggestion that humans have ever relied
on uncleaned organic produce for vitamin
b12 doesn't have any reliable evidence
at this time so the I just I don't know
where to go with these that claim
because it's just this demonstrably
false even from the perspective of a
vegan registered dietitian yes yeah I
don't know why he said that either but I
just think that that's something he
probably heard and he was probably
having a conversation with someone and
they told him that and he just repeated
it I mean it's one of those may be one
of the doctors on the show yes brought
that up so people repeat a lot of these
things and then they become Dogma so
here's the other thing the the second
part of that claim was up to 39% of
people tested including meat eaters are
low in b12 as a result best way for
humans to get enough b12 whether they
eat animal foods or not is simply to
take a supplement he didn't provide a
reference for that so I can't it's hard
to check that but again this contradicts
you know mounds of evidence on b12
deficiency so there you know there's
there's four stages of b12 deficiency I
don't want to go too far in the weeds
here but basically serum b12 which is
the marker that's usually used only goes
down in the fourth and final stage of
b12 deficiency there are other markers
that will go out of range earlier that
are more sensitive and detect those
earlier stages so the the most sensitive
markers holo transcript element or whole
OTC so in a study in 2013 this is a
slide 58 Jamie they compared b12
deficiency depletion according to holo
Transco Ballymun levels in vegetarians
vegans and omnivores and you can see the
results here only 11% of omnivores had
b12 depletion 77% of
and 92% of vegans that's a pretty big
difference it's a big difference that's
a big difference
b12 is responsible for energy that's
where the reasons why when people were
feeling sick they get a b12 shot well
it's also required for the myelin sheath
and our nerves b12 deficiency can cause
serious and even irreversible
neurological damage a lot of the harm
that comes that happens with kids on the
vegan diet comes from b12 deficiency can
decrease fluid intelligence it can cause
neurological damage that's not
reversible even after they start eating
meat again maybe that's what's going on
with them in this information maybe they
have legitimate neurological damage is
that possible it's possible there's more
because I'm just passionate about this
because it's super important slide 59 so
homocysteine is a marker that is also
more sensitive than serum b12 it's a
sticky inflammatory protein that's
associated with heart disease and
dementia so 9 out of 10 comparisons that
looked at b12 levels or homocysteine
levels and vegetarians and omnivores
found higher homocysteine levels in
vegans and vegetarians higher means
worse and it means more b12 deficient
and in fact the studies they said the
prevalence of hyper homocysteine amia
which is high homocysteine levels
reflecting low b12 among vegetarians may
actually be higher than among non
vegetarians already diagnosed with heart
disease so this is kind of a big deal
it's like the b12 issue is serious and
even folks like Jack Norris to their
credit do acknowledge it and and
strongly recommend that people who are
on a vegan diet supplement so if people
watch this film you know I'm glad to
hear James saying that that you know
vegetarians vegans should supplement
I don't think omnivores need to usually
but you can watch that film and get the
idea that that b12 you know is maybe not
that big of a deal right it's a big deal
[Applause]